on s'est réveillé avec de fortes
détonations
une forte détonation aux environs de 4
heures du matin puis un peu après 6
heures la sirène a retenti et on a dû
tous descendre dans l'abri souterrain
nous sommes ici dans un hôtel je vais
vous montrer un petit peu les lieux mais
tout d'abord pour vous dire que les
russes sont entrés dans kiev des forces
russes selon à certaines sources au sein
des forces du chrétiennes qui sont en
train de combattre des combats de rue
pas très loin d'ici environ quatre
stations de métro c'est ce qu'on nous
rapporte donc une situation extrêmement
tendue des bombardements des détonations
qu'on entend régulièrement et donc la
population intime à qui on a intimé
l'ordre de descendre aux abris je vais
vous montrer un petit peu là c'est notre
hôtel labrie est juste là on est sorti
quelques minutes pour pouvoir justement
vous parlez on va pas rentrer dans
l'abri mais vous pouvez voir ici des
réserves d'eau il y environ 50 personnes
amassées en bas il y a des enfants mais
aussi à des personnes âgées des
ukrainiens et puis des journalistes et
des gens qui sont encore inquiète
beaucoup ont déjà fui la ville mais il y
à de nombreux ukrainiens encore sur
place et la peur forcément et de se
faire encercler par les forces russes
qui semble donc être entré ici à kiev
une situation volatile tendu compliqué
pour tout le monde il semblerait qu'il y
ait des combats de rue on les a pas vus
mais c'est ce qu'on nous rapporte
notamment au sein des forces de sécurité
azu'u craignent n ont les témoignages
aussi à deux chars russes aux portes de
kiev et on sait qu'il y a eu des blessés
notamment chez les civils le maire de la
ville le maire de la ville de kiev a
déclaré qu'il y avait au moins trois
blessés un peu de confusion autour de ce
qui s'est passé il semblerait ce soit d
une roquette qui est touché un immeuble
civile ici il y à une des personnes qui
travaillent à l'hôtel qui vit non loin
de cet immeuble l'un et on va essayer
tout à l'heure d'avoir un petit peu plus
d'informations ce que sur ce qui s'est
passé mais je peux vous dire que la
situation est extrêmement tendue ici à
kiev c'était l'objectif
vraisemblablement des russes de venir
prendre la capitale ukrainienne et c'est
une situation extrêmement tendue pour
les ukrainiens il s'attendait à des
violences il s'attendait à ce que
l'armée russe arrive ici jusqu à kiev au
vu d opération éclair de ces derniers
jours ces opérations coordonnées sur
plusieurs fronts du pays mais les
ruelles mais les ukrainiens et encore il
ya quelques semaines quelques jours
n'imaginais pas que vous la dire me
woods a dit mi-août il ordonnerait la
des opérations aussi près de la capitale
russe de d'une telle envergure alors
hier avec abdallah malka wii qui est
avec moi mais aussi europe parsons pour
notre chaîne anglophone et bien nous
nous sommes promenés dans une capitale
vide quasi désert les gens sont partis
les restaurants les bars tous fermés
depuis la loi martiale décidées par le
gouvernement il ya aussi l état
d'urgence on a vu énormément de civils à
fuir la capitale kiev donc des
embouteillages un petit peu partout des
embouteillages un petit peu partout à la
sortie de la ville certains n'ont pas
réussi à partir aux premières heures de
l'opération
certains sont réussis donc à partir un
peu plus tard une situation forcément
compliqué pour eux en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que dans l'abri où
nous trouvons les ukrainiens font tout
pour que ça se passe bien font tout pour
assurer notre sécurité il avait prévu le
coup avec des vivres il ya de la
nourriture il y à de l'eau mais il ya
aussi des visage apeuré notamment des
enfants des jeunes enfants ukrainiens et
des vieilles dames qui sont présentes en
plus à des étrangers et les gens ici
forcément sont dans l'incompréhension
l'inquiétude la peur car les rues sont à
kiev